give them proof so I'm a big believer in
going in on projects when you're
passionate about something and I'll make
a lot of gut call decisions where people
won't understand it or agree with it at
the start because it only kind of exists
in my heart and then I'll just go and do
it and then want to show them this is
why it works this is why it's great and
it's easier for them to come on board
when they see it and they have proof
much more than just listening to an idea
when I'm starting on projects I'll try
to you know recruit people to help me
and get their advice and opinions and
feedback but if nobody wants to help me
I'll just go and do it I'll do it myself
I'll be an army of one we talked about
earlier today and just create it in
talking about my book I had this vision
for creating the book and everybody
thought most of the people that I talked
at the start thought it's a workbook
it's a it's a little kind of tiny
painful it but it's not there's not
enough content to make the book like you
guys maybe I'm not explaining it right
but you guys are missing the boat on how
much content could be created around
this idea and so I went out and created
it and end up writing 120 thousand words
when they wanted 60 and then up cutting
half the book how it's relevant now
what's happened this week in the book is
my editor wanted to cut a couple of
extra sections from the book couple
pages not not a huge deal but what I did
was I didn't just you know intuitively I
felt like I like those pages like this
is important this needs to be in here
it's part of the message everything that
is made it into the final cut I'm
attached to I feel needs to be there
it's super important when I had the book
out I gave it to 20 different people and
you guys saw kind of the recap and I had
them review it I had them underline it
and I took all of their feedback and me
to master copy and the pages that my
editor wants to cut the audience liked
there's comments as check marks as
underlines as highlights and because i
had that proof i can show that to my
editor and say listen it's not just me
saying I like it and I'm emotionally
attached to it I give it to the
people they think it's relevant they
think it's valuable and now it's a lot
harder for her to say no because there's
proof so show them right if if you have
something that you want to create don't
just accept their you know that the
other people's limiting views on it go
and show them show them that it works
give them proof that this can can create
something amazing and junior is brought
up an example about the belief video
when the the origin the you know Harry
that the dream killer the little man
told me that no video should be six and
a half minutes long I still went out and
made it and launched it and it has over
million views and was a super property
video and impacted well yeah is my first
one to get a million views yeah and so I
showed him right like here's the proof
and then that created a model doesn't go
do would have get into me and get so if
you have haters or doubters or people
around you who you know don't quite
believe in it then just go and show them
get them proved ok questions Q&A time
Peter I have a question I'm not super
skilled in one thing I don't think I
want to I got lots of basic knowledge on
different subjects I just don't know how
I could start a business this way I
really want to start my own business I
don't have a specialism unlike business
fitness books being outside my knowledge
is an excel nutrition business you know
or it gets stuck you have any
suggestions on how to work this problem
out well there's a few ways to look at I
mean there's always a place in the world
for generalists you never know if you
confound your focus or furnish like as
you explore you might find all I really
love doing this particular thing and I
want to get rid of the other things so
there's a whole bunch of like
experimentation but assuming that you
know variety is your thing or multi
disciplines you can use all those skills
Excel nutrition and business business
yes you can use all those skills to
create like to bring value to the world
to create a business around those
particular things maybe you release
workout spreadsheets really refine
complex work during spreadsheets and you
sell them as a business or I mean
there's a ton of options but I also
wouldn't put yourself in a box and be
like I don't like focusing on any one
particular thing i'm sure those people
exist but whether you're your whether
that's do or not remains to be seen yeah
i agree i think i think the genius isn't
combining all those things combining the
things that you love to make you
you and making that your business so
Excel nutrition and business if you try
to do just one of those things you would
suck at it because there are other
people who are better Excel than you
other people better at nutrition other
people better business than you but you
can be the best at combining those three
things together and there are people who
want that who want the best they want to
build a business around nutrition and
tracking it in Excel you can build a
business off of that and you could be
the best in the world at that and so
that's we should go and do and as you go
and explore new things and are
interested in other things bring that
into your business as well because if
you try just to do the one thing then
you won't be successful or successful
you could be take all the pieces of you
and put it together into one business
combine your passions combine your
passions that seems every video that's
an Evan video we had that somewhere
let's link that up well not over jay's
face let's link it up on my chest there
you go Patricia I'd love to see a video
series on the marketing efforts leading
up to the book's release oh yeah this is
exciting that's a common request aisle I
feel like this question comes up every
every time every book video and your
answer is usually I'm not focused on
that right now yeah we're almost there
I'm almost ready but it's exciting
starting to think of some things book
trailer yeah I started thinking so right
now it so right now where I'm at I don't
know what week this is right now where
I'm at is I have the close to final
version going back and forth with the
editor it's still missing my conclusion
there are still three things that I'm
I'm fighting over that we gotta figure
out and then the people that have done
guess contributions to the book I need
them to approve their sections and get
them to sign off on it and then I need
to write my conclusion and that's it and
so hopefully that will happen in the
next couple weeks and then it's we're
looking at early December release date I
think it's december six is okay so six
six or seven so from then on it's going
to be figuring out the marketing and I I
appreciate you want to hear about it so
that's why what this series will
transition to learning about I'm already
thinking about the market how to launch
I'm excited cuz there's been so much
about writing the book it's like I need
to get this away now now that I'm at the
point where I love what I've written
like it's ready the editor might think
it's ready the publisher i think is
ready but i think it's ready so it's
ready
and we need to we're going to cover we
need to wear I'm sure this thing's need
to work on the table of contents and
acknowledgments and whatever but but
like it's ready I want to get it out
let's start marketing it I'm excited to
market it I might spend so long of
creating this thing I want to get it out
so i'll keep you guys posted this has
been fun keeping people in the loop and
hearing your feedback and questions it's
fun it's keeping it secret and yeah well
you get the note but it soon oh this is
a long one ok Wang woo what's your take
on promoting your book door to door and
hitting the streets and cameras in your
book to your selecting audience
personally instead of sending them to
amazon or kindle or a website will they
have to take a cut from your book and
have to ship it out well I mean Taylor
Swift went to people's homes to give
them a Christmas present you responded
individually on like personal youtube
comment you made a video reply to people
yes I don't feel like you're anti door
to door or anti in person but it doesn't
seem that high leverage for the fitting
of the whole campaign like it so I mean
it's an idea certainly I'm feel like
Wang is asking this because of a
monetary reason I feel like that last
part because you will take a cut from
your book I didn't have to ship it out
you're not even doing this for money and
that's the thing like this is not a
financial reason for me launching the
book and if it were if you want to make
money just from selling a book
self-publishing is the easiest I don't
want to retract that don't easiest of
the way to do but is the way to go to
make more money balls cuz you keep the
most right like you get one hundred
percent of everything minus whatever
expenses that you have and so yeah door
to door even if it's on your own website
and then doing a campaign and going on
people's channels and promoting it it's
a way to do it it's just not interesting
for me because I wanted to reach
millions of people and so I'm okay with
losing a huge chunk of that if i can get
impact that can actually happen with
with self-publishing you can reach
millions but sure I mean there's a big
value in the middle man yeah I just
don't want it to come through that you
can't reach million something I can't
but it's harder well you know like if I
want you in the middle your goal is
awareness and your goal is to reach a
lot of people then you want to have a
team of people who are good at doing
that and they can round out your weak
spots so that's why I chose to go with
the Pope I would never I didn't want to
sell
ish it was never on my radar to
self-publish because it wasn't a
financial decision it was just her
opportunity so I think if that's your
goal you want to make money from a book
then yes look it's a publishing look at
how you can keep the most from it and
just hustle your way I don't know if
door-to-doors a highest leverage I'd be
looking at media I'd be looking at
connecting with youtubers and
instagramers and people have following
and getting them to review it and then
send it back to your website much more
effective than one at a time I build
through those kind of partnerships who
can i connect it with so that I can
reach a thousand people at a time or
10,000 or hundred thousand people a time
and not one at a time of going
door-to-door influencers with a plat
influence with the platform not
interesting to me though because it's
not my goal Tamara fabulous Nina is the
best wife ever I don't know if that's a
question but I concur fantastic right
and that's Nina we love her his special
I agree I agree Nina is a great way
that's why I've ever I love it it's her
birthday coming up actually this is
being released on the Saturday is her
birthday coming up so you can all wish
Nina a happy birthday in the comments my
yard organize a book launch create a
facebook event in north york and
streaming online i promise i will come
in person and support many people have
qualitative and inspirational thoughts
in their minds but the effort you've put
towards sharing yours with many others
is just respectful they don't know love
yeah it's so in terms of so that's back
to the marketing thing and i haven't
figured it out and I love all the ideas
that keep them coming if you have
thoughts or what I can do in the market
inside I will be likely doing some kind
of tour you know it makes sense to do
something where i am here locally in in
toronto and he's he's right here in
North York we're shooting in North York
we're in the Toronto dance salsa studio
here just shoot on empress walk north
you are young and empress yeah so so I
think one of the plans I'd like to do is
figure out where whether we do it by
pre-orders or how we're going to do it
but stop in at different places stream
some events have people who bought some
books be on the video so if we do like a
top 10 video have some of the google
bought the books be in the videos and
and sharing their thoughts or sharing
its ryan so far like I think would be
you know my publisher advised me against
doing a book tour basically saying you
don't make money from a book tour
because the people that you reach at
those locations don't buy enough books
to justify the
the return but for me I'd be looking at
how can I turn that into an online event
that we can then leverage Sam rock great
message today FM and who used to call me
of somebody to come here ethanol monkey
now like from my youth somebody to call
me Abe yeah my parents gave me a short
name because they didn't want people
with no shame and it's still like I
having four letters nobody's gonna
shorten it they didn't want to call me
like jonathan is not be junk syllables
right so yeah so they were and now
everybody's gonna call me Abe this is
going to be epic you're entitled and
fetches I'd you've got me pup now you'll
be on Oprah soon enough nice no
questionnaire but feeling the love i
love it the cooper 841 the audio version
would be awesome for the ones who live
outside the US I'm so happy for your
success and sense of accomplishment
can't wait to have your book I think I
now said we're doing an audio Bible are
hungry for the oh yeah the audiobook is
gonna come and I haven't talked about
the details again but I think also I
mentioned I i I'm gonna insist on
reading it I don't see why they wouldn't
want me to read it I think if you can
ever get the author to read it it's
better I and I think some others may not
have the skills or the interest they may
be lazy and they're just mailing it in
and just I'm just doing on the book I
don't want to burn audio and then you
get somebody else to do it or they may
not have the skills to speak and they
you know they're not comfortable in
their voice or whatever I have the
skills and so I'm gonna do it and and
it's gonna be all hell if they don't
want me to read the audio version I'm
gonna freak out if they don't want more
you gotta double via but it would make
sense I don't know why they wouldn't it
be I don't know why they would although
if it wasn't me who would you want to
have read the audio for all Morgan
Freeman Morgan Freeman no no no you know
I would want I would want like I
wouldn't want young Les Brown reading it
young lamb yeah spit in the fire he's
gotten a lot mellower now but but young
last friend are we ready for him or we
can have eric thomas read it lesson
young young les brown but y les brown i
love young les brown men don't stop
running to watch your dream who would
you have read your book if I met you by
wrote a book he wrote a book if I wrote
a book if I had a melee you get out I
did Gary Vee you were comparing
really really area see similar brashness
or whatever so I'd write it and he could
probably pull it off you know I feel I
feel it now I feel like you need to go
like Kanye or jay-z you gotta go bigger
I'm trying to think I think about the
artistry right whatever I write it has
to come out of their mouth so it has to
its kind of match i right and I don't
think feel like Jay or Kanye talk like I
talk may be telling you all right okay
but he said Gary Vee I'm a fan I'm a fan
okay last question rishi Cup TV and when
you're all about standing up and
providing value through core values so
keep fighting man my question did you
have the full vision for your book when
you began or did you just take action
and vision king so this is an
interesting one to two parts on this
first part was I never wanted to write a
book my agent I have a talent agent and
then a really called what's the other
agent no no literary agent literary
agents are just four books and then my
talent agents for other speaking gigs
other kinds of my talent agent insisted
that i needed a book that a book would
make me huge it was huge credibility and
that mainstream companies and media
would pay more attention to me and I was
like you know I don't care I don't
really need a book it's not it's not
that big a deal but you want to go pitch
a book and we get a good you know vibe
and opportunity sure I'm all for it so
we pitched a book initially around
modeling success is a concept that I'm
you know that is core to what I'm all
about but I wasn't passionate right in
that book so we started talking with
literary agent and she was on board
because she liked me she liked me she
liked yacht and she like we could do and
that was the initial idea and then
halfway through making the pitch in the
sample chapter for that I came up with
the idea for the book that I wanted to
write like oh this is the book I want to
write yeah I don't like Nina Nina Nina's
my wife pnina's awesome i need any na is
my media I'm not muted well you got me
stinky Middlebury literary agent and
like Nina we're switching it this is the
book that I want to ride and again her
aunt and my other agent didn't think it
was a book but i managed to show them
back to the topic that it was and then
when i was thinking of it I didn't have
it all worked out I had there's three
sections to the book I had one and two
pretty well worked out there was some
extra research i need to do extra
stories in need to tell
but i knew what i wanted to write for
the most like for the first two sections
that was you know us working on the
business and discussions and things that
you know be interested as or for a
number of well for the past year plus
and plus my story coming into it section
three I had no idea and that actually
got created by me going out and meeting
people and interviewing people and
seeing how they were doing some things
in that that helped shape how i created
the book because the book that I'm
writing is is how to build a certain
kind of company and nobody has ever
really built this kind of company before
and so there was no handbook oh they
built like parts of this kind of company
but nobody has gone through it
methodically because there was no
guidebook there's no handbook and so
people were doing it on their own and
just kind of struggling their way to
find their success and so I thought well
by bringing all these different pieces
from two people together we can build
the ultimate company that is not the
title of a book but it's like back
jacket I don't like that we're giving
stuff away marketing secret now we're
not using that anyway so I didn't
promise that I knew exactly what the
sections were going to be I just kind of
give an overview and when you're
pitching a book you have to you have to
give an overview and then they want a
sample chapter so I did that based on
what I already knew I was gonna write
and just give an overview of what I want
in section 3 but had no idea what the
breakdown was gonna be and the parts
that I wrote in were maybe half a
curative what actually made it into the
book but it didn't matter for the pitch
and then once we got the calls of the
publishers and we got an agreement
wasn't a big deal and then I went
figured it out I had a good idea of what
I wanted to do and how I would do it but
they were still chunks while third of
the book that was missing I think I just
take out a coach a lot with stuff in
general right you have an idea but you
know as entrepreneurs we don't have it
all worked out we don't know exactly how
it's gonna play out you just you start
and and then you you you figure out
parts of it as you go along and you do a
check olders yeah you just you make it
better when you're creating anything you
just all core is here vers here uh I
think it's
have a bridge and he moved stuff around
it's like a limb loss think this is
where perfectionism could kill
businesses because you think you need to
have the whole thing figured out from
the start and that was me and my first
business where I would spent three
months working on the perfect business
plan when I thought it was perfect and
then as soon as I went out and tried to
sell stuff it was wrong so you can't
build the perfect plan what doesn't mean
have no plan and just who do whatever
you start with an intention and you
start with you know what you have in
your head you start with creating
something you always have to figure some
of it out as you go and don't let the
perfectionism kill you I did it with my
recent checklist start writing add the
story cut the story throw it out try
again next year I like it solid episode
oh ok let me know what you guys think
let me know what you think about the
topic what was the topic shall show them
demonstrate prove it let me know what
you guys think of that topic if you have
questions and if you have any thoughts
or questions about my book the book
writing process marketing the book I'd
love to hear from you leaving the
comments below thank you guys for
watching continue to believe whom and
we'll see you soon